皆さん今でしょ
どういうた顔です
私はこの4月1日に京都大学注意ニットに着任しました
私が京都大学に来る前役
20年にわたって日本の有人宇宙活動の前線で働いていました
今日はこの私の経験を皆さんに
落ち対しななら
ゆ受注活動を人が宇宙へ行くということはどういうことなのか一緒に考えたいと思い
ますどうぞよろしくお願いします
日本の有人宇宙活動1985年に始まりました
3人の宇宙飛行士が選ばれました
毛利さん江迎さんそして私です
毛利さんは1992年にアメリカのスペースシャトルコロンビアがを塗って宇宙実験を
しました
1985年永劫やまぁだいたい2年に一度ぐらいの割合で日本人の
宇宙活動が始まりましたそれは2008年まで続きます
この1985年から2008年までのこの期間を言う受注活動の大毅と呼んでいます
この期間では一つのミッションごとに新しい有人宇宙技術を ao というそういう
努力がされてきましたそして2008年に
至ります2008年に何が起こったかというと日本の国際宇宙ステーションきぼう
モジュールが宇宙に行きました
25年に及ぶ努力の成果です
この2008年以後私たちは有人宇宙活動日本の有人宇宙活動の第2期と呼んでます
ですか今私たちがいる今この時間はこの時はイオンの余裕中うち活動の第2期にわたっ
ています
この第2期をもう少し詳しく見てみましょう
まず2008年ですけども私のフライトで
希望のモジュール a
1番目のモジュールが宇宙に行きましたその後星出さんは嘉田さんと続いて3つの50
るが宇宙に行って希望のモジュールが完成されましたでは方さあいい子
日本の宇宙飛行士による長期滞在が始まりました
で特に2010年野口さんをフライトんと
時に山崎さんが宇宙に行きましたちょうどこの時ですから宇宙には2人の日本人がいた
ことになります
新しい宇宙飛行士のグループの皆さんも飛び始めています
昨年より君はさんが宇宙聖書んに滞在しました
また大237月から現在まで宇宙ステーション滞在しています彼は
今週ですね
日本が地球に戻ってくることになっています
来年 a 金井さんが宇宙ステーションに飛ぶ予定です
日本の宇宙ステーション活動
2,000円
この予定だと24年まで続くことになっています
ここで一つ問題があります
問題は2025年以降の日本の有人宇宙活動計画ができてないことです
2025年まで約もう
8年とちょっとしかないです府中いう中中活動っていうのは10年15年かかりもそう
いう意味で
もう日本は今この時に
2025年以降の有人宇宙活動計画を作りつがありますがまだそれができていません
ここでへ
超私の
宇宙ミッションを皆さんに紹介したいと思います
スペースシャトルエンデバー号よって
8年3月11日宇宙に行きました
2本の柱ステーションきぼうの第一便です
これはちょうどもようなこの打ち上げでしたので
ちょうどちゃん4写真はこんな感じになりますでスペースシャトルエンデバー号
全重量がに戦闘ありますですからだいたい小型車
2000台分の重さのものが宇宙に飛んでいくというわけですごい世界最高生のダウン
員法の
ろ決闘でした
宇宙まで8分30秒で到達してしまいます
8分30秒というと非常に短く感じはありますが
その最終速度は秒速8km まで上がります
秒速8km というと
1分間に500km いきますから今ちょうど皆さん寝る子の共闘立って1分後には
東京を超えてい払い件あたりまで行ってしまうというそういうすごい
スピードまで到達します
このミッションのために私たちは2年間の
訓練をしましたここに写っているのが私の仲間たちでし
この年間の訓練期間中もちろんスペースシャトルを使えるようになること
宇宙ステーションの各機器を使えるようになること
まあそういう宇宙での仕事についていろんな訓練をしましたが私にとって
一つとても大事だったことがありますそれはチームワークを作ることです
宇宙柄は一人では行けません
宇宙という真空無重量環境たくさんの人たちが一丸になって働いてはじめて実現でき
ます
このチームワークは
自分が自分のメンバーを信じられるか
自分の命を預けられるかまた自分の仲間たちが
自分を信じてくれるか命預けてくれるかそういう意味で
自分の命を預けることができるチームワークを作るということが宇宙ミッションには
必要です
この2年間を通して
このならにまた地上でへサポートしてくれる人々とのチームワーク
うまく作れてそれが今自分にとって本当に大きな財産になっています
これが私たちが入った宇宙ステーションです
これは2011年に完成した時の写真です
日本の人権利権頭が希望のモジュールがそのセンターについています宇宙ステーション
は地上から400km の行動飛んでます
このコード秒速8km で回っています
そうすると何が起こるかというと90分で地球の周りを一周しますですから45分ごと
に昼と夜がきます宇宙ってのはそういう不思議な世界です大きさはちょうど区の a
左から右端まで110メートルあります
対応電池パネルが4組ついていますこの対応電池パネルの
長さは70メートルありますからこの全体の大きさっていうのはちょうど
サッカー場1個の
大草にあたります重量は約420トン
人間が宇宙へ作った世界最大の構造物です
今現在6人の宇宙飛行士が長寺滞在して
宇宙空間で地球を観測したり家の観測したりまた新しい科学技術の発見を目指して
いろいろな
実験落ちています
宇宙
無重力の世界ですこんな
仲間との集合写真が簡単に撮れます
無重力の世界すべて異論すべてのものが浮いている世界
いつもつけもない世界です
1961年にいいかガーリンが初めて
宇宙に行きましたでその時私たちはいろんな疑問を持っていました
宇宙で人間は生きていくことができるのか
水を飲むことができるのかたいものを食べることができるのか
寝ることができるのかきちんと考えることができるのか
仕事ができるのかいろんなあ義務を持っていました
今私たちは全ての疑問に答えることができます
宇宙で人間は治療と同じように生活し
仕事をすることができます
水を飲むことも食べることも治療と同じように何の努力もが普通にすることができます
よく眠ることができますものを考えることができな仕事もできます何でも自由に一応と
同じように私たちは宇宙で活動することができます
この人間の体地上で
生まれて育って進化して
この地上の1 g の世界しか知らないこの体が宇宙の無重力状態でもフィチンと働く
ことができるように作られている
これは本当に素晴らしいことだと思います
その結果として私たちは宇宙へ展開する力を持っていることになります
の有人宇宙活動私がこの京都大学に来た時にでは京都大学で自分は一体何ができる
だろうかと自分に質問しました
その答えがこれです
有人宇宙活動を担う高い専門性を持つ次世代人材の育成をしてやろうと思いました
乳汁中活動はまた新しいことへチャレンジする挑戦していく活動でもありますですから
高い存問性を待つという代わりに新しいことにチャレンジしていく実在人材の育成と
言い換えてもいいかと思います
有人宇宙活動は3つの特徴を持っていますひとつは
最先端科学技術を使うということ人が
無重力真空環境に行くためには本当に今使える西センターの母美術が必要です
また人が行くということから人文社会的連携も必要になります
もちろん人が犬をかけて a
新しい挑戦するわけですから国民の関心が高いです
このような友人活動を引っ張っていく
若い人達が多くなればもちろんいう中活動が活性化しますそれはまた宇宙官室の利用に
拡大に
つながり宇宙産業が拡大していきます
流通産業またそれを地上の色々な暮らし
活動に広げることによって社会的効果としては社会全体で新しい産業が生まれると言っ
ていいと思います
もう少しすると宇宙から新しい産業革命が起こると私は信じています
その結果としてもちろん国民の高い関心が
さらに高くなって総数とこの星のループが起こるとすると宇宙活動がますます盛んに
なっているとそれを目指したしたいと思いました
ところが一つ問題がありますそれは先ほど言った
日本は2025年以降有人宇宙活動計画を持っていないということはそれは何かという
と
宇宙ステーション活動はこの下に向きの矢印に相当していますそれはまだこの
上向きの矢印に変換してないですね
それはなぜかと考え時にやはり宇宙湯受注活動を志すやはり
若い人材が育っていない
でもう一つ
原因があると思いました
それは
宇宙活動人が宇宙に行くということを語るべき
学問が存在していないっていうことですね
そこで私がここに来て有人宇宙凧作ろうと皆さんに今働きかけている最中です
u 10中学は人間と宇宙を繋ぐ
学問
んです
今でもちろん人間と超乙な学問というのは作られてきましたちょうど
皆さんから得て好み以外に乗っているところですね宇宙工学や家をたぬ県中学新に開く
また宇宙科学
家地球科学そういう学問が作られてきていました
麻里江ワークを中心とした学問が作られていました
人が宇宙に行くということによっても超社会学とか経済学とかそういう人文社会科学系
の額もちょっとだけ使われるようになってますがまあこれを見ると
とも学問と言うには
底が浅い
奥行きがないこれだとやはり
人々を訴える力がない何か足りないものがある
人間と宇宙を繋ぐ間に何か一つ欠けている
そう感じましたそれでいろいろ考えましたそれで見つけたのがこれです
時間を入れてやろうと思いましたそうそう何ができるかというと
人間宇宙時間をつなぐこの三角形ができますと三角形を支えている顎もうを全部
融合して有人宇宙学を作ろうと考えました
例えば宇宙と時間を
結ぶ痩せる氏はカープや物理学天文学数学があります
人間や時間を結ぶ矢印や歴史がから始まって生理学偽悪場であります
そういう
人間が今まで作ってきたほとんどあらゆる学問というのがこの有人宇宙学に含まれると
いうことになります
またこれここに経をあげている学問というのは地球上で地球
人類が地上できて二ために作った書くもんですこれは宇宙では約疑い
宇宙で人間が展開するためにはしてを宇宙に上げて夢中で使える学問にしないといけ
ないですから今私たちはこういう術との学問を宇宙レベルに引っ張りあげようという
そう
努力を始めたところです
この u 10中学私たちの現実の世界に
ついてみたのが
このスライドです
宇宙と時間それは何を意味するか宇宙の進化ですねビッグバーンから始まって銀河系が
でき惑星系ができた宇宙の進化
100-9年を語る学問分野です
それから人間と時間を2つありますまず生命の新刊
海で生命が生まれて陸に上がりそれから
宇宙に行こうとしている今生命の進化を語る時間
1億年の時間ですそれからへ
人間が知恵をもって村を作り
町をつくって都市を作る約1万年に及ぶ時間つける
これも
私たちの有人宇宙や口に入ってきますこの4つの分野がまとまって
人間が家へ行くための学問が作るんじゃないかと考えました
そのために最低この4つの分野を研究する研究班をつくりました
研究班1話宇宙の進化家を知る研究ハ
研究班には政務の進化家を生きることを知る
研究する
研究ハそれから研究班さんは文明の進化
宇宙を考える宇宙で考える研究班それからね宇宙でものを付ける研究班4宇宙でつける
別を付ける研究班4です
この活動は今まだ始まったばかりですここに来られての皆さん
もし興味があるならば
どうぞ
いう受注額の創出に参加してください
私の今までの宇宙体験を
考えると2つ印象に残りますひとつは宇宙から見る地球の素晴らしさです
しかし右中間へと同時に地球な1つの惑星であるということがわかります
それは幽玄な世界です地球上のすべての生命学の一つの世界にしか存在していない
この素晴らしい地球これからも守っていかなければいけないと強く感じました
4発目はアーミンあー素晴らしいかあの大な構造劇他人へ方はた
鯱人間が力を合わせれば可能であると
思います最後に
私の大好きな言葉をみなさんに贈ります
家を目指せみなさん今日はどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]